military investigators will try to
determine what caused a plane crash that
kills sixteen servicemembers in rural
Mississippi the kc-130 went down
yesterday in a bean field the wreckage
burned overnight the Marine Corps says
only that the refueling and transport
plane experienced a mishap bodies were
found more than a mile away from the
main crash site david beg no is near the
site in e2 baina Mississippi that's
about 100 miles south of Memphis David
good morning Nora good morning the
Marine Corps just put out a statement
five minutes ago confirming that this
aircraft left Cherry Point North
Carolina yesterday now we're being kept
about five miles from the crash site and
part of the reason why is because you've
got wreckage strewn for miles as well as
body parts witnesses report this plane
was on fire as it fell from the sky in
broad daylight firefighters initially
responding to the wreckage report an
explosion that required them to retreat
for their own safety this wreckage
burned for at least six hours when the
rescue crews arrived heavy flames and a
smoldering wreckage were all that
remained of the Marine Corps Reserve
transport aircraft crews rushed to put
out the fire and search for survivors at
least 16 people have been killed you
know state agent okay ages prior to
problems first responders we had a lot
of agencies out Leflore County official
Fred Randall insists that the area
around the crash site is still unsafe we
don't know yeah fuel everywhere so we
don't want anybody without responders in
the area the plane is a kc-130
four-engine turboprop plane it was being
tracked by air traffic controllers in
nearby Memphis Tennessee at 20,000 feet
it suffered a catastrophic failure
plunging out of the sky as it started to
fall the plane went radio silent
the kc-130 can be used to refuel other
planes in midair and often carries
additional fuel as a result
witnesses say the aircraft caught fire
and spun as it
bodies were found throughout the
surrounding area plumes of thick black
smoke could be seen for miles
the FBI is assisting in this
investigation and since last night the
military has been rushing to get to the
family members of those killed before
they heard it somewhere else
Gail from the aerial photos we've seen
parts of this plane are still largely
intact and that from aviation experts
they have told us that would indicate
that an explosion is highly unlikely in
terms of what brought this plane down
well a lot of questions about what
happened there thank you very much David